if we were to go
and put ourselves on another planet
which plant do you think it would be do
you think it'd be mars or would it be
would it be a proxima b so
that there are two planets that are
closest to us and in principle
uh could have life on them or we could
imagine going there
and changing conditions such that we
could live there
they are mars and venus on the two sides
of the earth
mars used to have an atmosphere and
probably had conditions similar to earth
early on in its
life but then because it's ten times
less
massive than the earth it couldn't hold
on to its atmosphere so the atmosphere
evaporated
and then it lost the potential for
for liquid water on its surface because
you can't have liquid water unless
there is an atmospheric pressure and so
even if there was life on mars um it
couldn't
continue uh there was no liquid water
available
and the perseverance mission will
actually get there
in february 2021 in about in less than
in a few weeks actually and we'll figure
out whether
there was or maybe there is some left
the other signatures of life in the
martian soil and so that would be very
exciting and
we i i'm very much looking forward to
seeing the results from this mission
um but then going there for us for
humans
would require a lot of adaptation
because just standing on the surface of
mars
without an atmosphere without a strong
magnetic field that mass doesn't have
we will be exposed to energetic
particles cosmic rays
that could damage within a year you will
have a substantial damage to
the cells in your brain and you need
protection
uh from that and one way to protect our
bodies is to go
underground to go into a cave or to
build some infrastructure that will
protect us
there is not enough attention given to
that so just sending humans to mars
without proper protection
would be irresponsible it's sort of like
a death sentence
you don't want to do that so we need to
come up with the solutions to protect
people that go there
but potentially it's a place that we
could then
modify such that we could live there
and you can imagine not necessarily
going to a planet
you can put some platform in space
you know we we started in the jungles of
africa and we
ended up in apartment buildings in
cities uh that's a big leap
over a period of a hundred thousand
years uh
i don't see the leap from an apartment
building
you know in a city in manhattan to to
going to space as big
as the leap from uh africa to
to an apartment building you know so we
could do it
it will require some time but you know a
hundred thousand years is a huge
uh period you know over which we will
have technologies that are far superior
to what we have now so
i'm quite optimistic that we could adapt
to like living in space
but it will take some time and then
venus uh
venus right now on the surface has
you know it went through uh greenhouse
effect and
the surface is extremely hot it cannot
sustain liquid water
you cannot live on the surface of venus
uh there was
some suggestion that maybe there is life
in the clouds of venus
so the only way for us to inhabit venus
would be to terraform it to change the
conditions such that it's not as
as hot as it is but then of course
we can go to proxima b we can go to
another
star the nearest star is proxima
centauri and
it has a habitable planet next to it uh
and that planet displays our star that
it has a permanent dayside and a
permanent night side
uh and my daughters say that
uh the the the strip that separates
those two sides
is the most would have the highest real
estate value because it will be a
permanent sunset
strip and have a house there you can see
the sunset
forever for dummies like myself who've
never heard of proxima b or proxima
the other one can you explain where they
are and
where what they are yeah proxima
centauri
is a member of a three star system that
is the closest
to the sun right now i mean it will
continue to be the closest star system
to us
for about a hundred thousand years so
every hundred thousand years or so there
is a new star coming closest to us
and then it's passing um and right now
proxima centauri
is the nearest and it's actually a dwarf
star that is only
12 percent of the mass of the sun so
it's much fainter
most of the stars are much smaller and
fainter than the sun
uh so we live next to an unusual star
most of the stars are
are like proxima centauri and then
it has roughly half the surface
temperature
that the sun has only 3 000 degrees
kelvin
compared to almost 6 000 that the sun
has
and therefore it emits mostly infrared
light
the sun emits mostly visible light
that's why our eyes are tuned
to visible light but the creatures if
there are any creatures on the habitable
planet next to proxima centauri
they should have infrared eyes which
would be very strange for us to see
actually uh and if there is any grass
growing there
it will be dark red so if you think
about
interstellar travel agencies designing
trips if most of the
living creatures are living near dwarf
stars that are the most common
uh they are used to red to dark red
grass and they will never come to a
planet like ours that offers
green grass that will not be a desirable
tourist destination because they don't
like this color
they enjoy having a vacation on a dark
red
grass you know and that may explain why
we haven't seen any
visit us can you explain a little bit
more
what would the eyes of the beings on
that planet look like why would they be
what would an infrared eye look like i
don't know it would look
shocking to us it would look very
different than our eyes
so our eyes were developed over time to
uh take advantage of most of the light
produced by the sun
which is visible light but if you are
next to a star that produces mostly
infrared radiation then evolution would
lead you to be sensitive
to that kind of light you know this is
the kind of light you get from
warm objects you know like um
uh soldiers have those goggles that are
sensitive to infrared radiation
at night when there is at night there is
not much in
uh visible light because you are on the
other side of the earth where the sun is
not
around and you know and and and but
objects are warm enough to emit infrared
radiation and
and you can see them with these goggles
that's what they saw
you know people that have infrared
goggles
can see the heat emitted by bodies that
are warm
and that's that's the kind of infrared
radiation
that the star proxima centauri
is mostly a meeting so of course if we
had goggles
infrared goggles we would see that
radiation very clearly
but those animals creatures that may be
born there
they have those sensors infrared sensors
um that they are born with because that
gives them an evolutionary advantage
uh the reason we have visible light eyes
is because it gives us an advantage we
can survive better if we see the light
from the sun because
it's reflected of objects so we can
protect ourselves if
if there is something endangering us we
can
avoid that danger by seeing that object
and that's why we have sensitivity to
visible light which is the most common
type of light near the sun
but if we were next to proxima centauri
it would not offer us much of much
advantage and
then probably we would not survive and
animals that have
infrared eyes would survive because they
can see the danger
uh if there is another animal coming to
eat them they would be able to escape
because they're sensitive to infrared
light which is the most common form of
light
in their environment